[Musique]
bonsoir il y a 50 ans le 16 juillet 1945
les AM américain expérimenté dans le
désert du Nouveau-Mexique la première
bombe atomique de l'histoire quelques
jours plus tard le 6 août Hiroshima
était rasé 4 ans après en août 1949
l'Union soviétique faisait exploser à
son tour sa première bombe atomique nous
allons raconter ce soir comment l'Union
soviétique a eu la bombe grâce aux
recherches de ses savants ou grâce au
travail de ses espions nous sommes à
Cambridge qui est non seulement une
université prestigieuse mais un des haut
lieux du renseignement cinq des plus
grands espions du siècle ont fait leurs
études ici à bridge deux d'entre eux
mlein et Ken cross ont joué un rôle
actif dans l'espionnage atomique nous
allons raconter cette histoire en
compagnie du professeur Christopher
Andrew qui est historien ici à Cambridge
et spécialiste des questions de
renseignement tout de suite les débuts
de la recherche sur la bombe
atomique
1933 avec l'arrivée au pouvoir d'adolp
Hitler le temps de la terreur commence
en Allemagne le soir du 10 mai 1933
devant l'université de Berlin
des milliers de sa mettent le feu à une
montagne de livre les nazis purifient la
culture et la science germanique et
prennent les premières mesures
antisémites pour les scientifiques
souvent d'origine juive l'heure de
l'exil a
sonné à l'automne 1933 Albert Einstein
le plus grand physicien vivant émigre
pour les États-Unis il se rend à
l'université de Princeton
d'autres savants immigrés se retrouvent
en Angleterre auou Canada en
France cependant c'est en Amérique que
se concentre une formidable communauté
d'esprits
[Musique]
scientifiques en mars 1939 Frédéric
jolio Curri Hans Alban et lev kovarski
au Collège de France suivi dans leur
découverte une semaine plus tard par HRI
ferm et lo zillard de l'Université de
Colombia à New York démontre que la
rupture d'un noyau d'uranium libère une
énorme quantité d'énergie et permet
l'émission de plusieurs neutrons qui
provoquent à leur tour de nouvelles
[Musique]
fissions
convaincu par zilard de la possibilité
d'une réaction en chaîne Albert Einstein
rédige le 2 août 1939 une lettre au
président rosevel il informe de la
possibilité de construire une bombe d'un
type nouveau d'une puissance
terrifiante on peut dater de cette
lettre le début du projet atomique
américain en octobre Roosevelt décide de
créer un comité consultatif de l'uranium
qui réunit les scientifiques les plus
renommés à peine un mois après l'appel
d'Einstein le 1er septembre 1939 la
guerre éclate en
Europe l'année suivante à l'université
de Colombia Enrico Fermi est responsable
des recherches sur la réaction en chaîne
par neutron LAN avec Léo zilar il prouve
que le carbone sous forme de graphite
très pur peut servir de modérateur dans
cette réaction en chaîne à l'université
de Berkley en Californie Ernest Laurence
l'inventeur du cyclotron un accélérateur
de particules travaille en parallèle
avec le chimiste Glen cborg qui parvient
à isoler le plutonium élément de base
pour l'un des deux procédés de
fabrication d'une bombe
[Musique]
atomique
en Union soviétique la création d'une
commission de l'uranium est décidé en
1940 Piot capizza joue un rôle décisif
dans la mise en route du programme
nucéaire somité scientifique il a quitté
en 1934 l'Université de Cambridge en
Grande-Bretagne il est nommé directeur à
l'Académie des Sciences de Moscou tandis
que deux jeunes physiciens obtiennent
les premiers résultats concluants en
matière d'uranium
[Musique]
le 22 juin 1941 la vermart envahurss
l'ofensif de l'armée allemande sur
Moscou suspend un temps les travaux des
scientifiques soviétiques mais pasux des
espions fin 1941 Staline est informé de
sources sûres que les britanniques
tentent de se doter d'une bombe à
l'énergie
atomique
[Musique]
les services soviétiques décident alors
d'intensifier la collecte de
renseignement sur la BoM aux
États-Unis grgory Résid du NKVD à San
Francisco s'intéresse en particulier au
chercheurs travaillant sur l'énergie
atomique le 6 décembre
1941 sous la couverture de monsieur Brun
viceconsul soviétique approche l'un de
ses savants Robert
openenheimer
coïcidence le même jour Roosevelt prend
la décision de doter les États-Unis de
la bombe
atomique le 7 décembre 1941 l'aviation
japonaise bombarde la base américaine de
perbour
les États-Unis rentrent dans la
guerre dans la course à la bombe les
Russes mettent les bouché doubl le 10
mars 1942 à partir de rapports fournis
par différents agents de renseignement
en Occident Beria informe Staline que
des recherches ont été entamé sur les
possibilités d'utiliser l'énergie
nucléaire de l'uranium à des fins
militaires sur un plan scientifique en
juin le jeune physicien igorov est nommé
à la tête du programme pour la
réalisation d'une arme atomique en ce
qui concerne l'espionnage un département
spécial est créé Pavel Platov est chargé
de fédérer toute la collecte de
renseignement sur la recherche du
programme nucléaire américain dans cet
entretien inédit réalisé en avril 1992
que nous avons retrouvé à Moscou donne
version des fa ce témoignage capit
pourantre pris avec
précaution
quand j'ai reçu l'ordre de diriger les
renseignements dans le domaine atomique
Beria était l'organisateur de cette
affaire il m'a convoqué et m'a dit de
former le département s SOP Platov dans
lequel il y avait de grands spécialistes
qui travaillaient sur les documents des
services secrets concernant le problème
atomique aux éats-unis et en
Angleterre
aux États-Unis les recherches mené
jusqu'alors dans qu centres Colombia
Princeton Chicago Berkley sont
[Musique]
coordonné
à 6 mois près pour la dernière étape le
programme sera scrupuleusement
respecté à la mi-epembre 1942 le général
les Richard grov est désigné pour
diriger l'ensemble des travaux visant à
la réalisation de la bombe atomique
américaine le projet a pour nom de code
Manathan
le 2 décembre 1942 date historique de l'
atomique c'est à Chicago kenco ferm
constructeur de la première pile
atomique c'estàdire du réacteur réussit
une expérience décisive il déclenche une
réaction en chaîne et la contrôle
l'homme sit désormais commander les
atomes la réussite de Fermi donne au
projet manatan une impulsion
décisive soulatov est informé de la
nouvelle grâce à un rapport transmis par
un proche collaborateur d'Enrico Fermi
le savant Bruno pont Corvo dont le
message codé arrivera à la loubianca
siège du KGB le marin italien a atteint
le Nouveau
Monde
and c'est en 43 les résultats des
expériences de Ferm reçu de pon
Corvo là je vous le signale tout le
temps il s'agit pas de dire c camarad
Camar je parle comme avant que savant ét
nos agents dieu m'en garde il s'agit pas
de
cel Québec d'OT 1943 chchi obtient de
Roosevelt un accord de collaboration
atomique signé conjointement entre les
Américains les Anglais et les Canadiens
les savants britanniques viennent
travailler en
Amérique aux États-Unis au cours de
l'été 1943 trois centres destinés à la
réalisation de la bombe atomique sont
créés à Arich première usine au monde de
diffusion gazeuse à hford où se
construisent les trois réacteurs
nucléaires à salamos où les
scientifiques travaillent à la
réalisation de la bombe elle-même sous
la direction de Robert
openenheimer alors Christopher andrw
très tôt dès le début de la guerre les
Russes ont su que les Anglais les
Américains avaient commencé à préparer
une bombe atomique alors de quelle
source dans ces années 40 41 disposai
les les Russes pour être aussi bien
informé le source principale à cette
époque là c'était un ancien étudiant de
Trinity College Cambridge
qui exactement deom Joh kcoss c'éit un
étudiant brillant d'ailleurs linguiste
quelqu'un qui a écrit deux livres dans
la langue française sur mière qui a
traduit les œuvres de Racine céit plus
tard un peu plus tard en anglais mais il
a été recruté par le
KGB pendant qu'il était étudiant à à
Trinity College dans les années 30 dans
les années 30
le KGB lui avait demandé de pénétrer
d'abord dans le ministère des Affaires
étrangères britanniques c'estàd le
Foreign Office en 36 ensuite le
ministère des Finances
britanniqueasy en 38 mais son premier
grand succès ça a été de devenir
secrétaire particulier de Lord han
ministre de Winston Churchill en
et qui était présidé par mal de comités
euh parmi ces comités un comité
scientifique consultatif qui dès 1940
euh considérit la construction d'une
bombe atomique l'un des officiers
tritant du KGB de de kencoss a récemment
confirmé que John kcoss ancien étudiant
de Trinity College Cambridge a été le
premier à avertir euh Moscou de la
construction d'une bombe
anglo-américaine et en tant que
secrétaire il avait accès à à ces
documents c'est certain parce que
pendant un certain temps johas était
secrétaire non seulement de Lord Hany
mais secrétaire du comité consultative
scientifique qui délibérait la
construction d'une bombe atomique
anglo-américaine mais très vite les
Anglais les scientifiques anglais les
scientifiques américains ont commencé à
travailler à collaborer ensemble alors
donc comment se passait cette ce travail
commun alors les physiciens nucléaire
anglo-américain ont commencé une
collaboration en
1941 mais c'est seulement à partir de
1943 que les physiciens nucléaires
britanniques on commencer une
collaboration directe en se rendant à
Los ALM laboratoire
cl américaine mais justement nous allons
le voir maintenant tout ça en
image en 1944 c'est àogordo dans le
désert du Nouveau-Mexique à 260 km de
losalamos que le général groves choisit
d'expérimenter la première bombe
atomique ayant pour nom de code
Trinity la face finale de la
construction de la bombe exige dans le
secret absolu la création d'une base où
se concentrent les plus grands savants
pas moins de 12 prix Nobel travaill sous
une étroite
surveillance ces scientifiques souvent
d'origine européenne redoutent que
l'Allemagne Nazi possède la première la
bombe atomique il pense que les secrets
atomiques doivent être partagés avec
l'URSS qui est une
[Musique]
allié
les démarches de nilsbor traduisent les
préoccupations de ses savants B est
convaincu que l'Union soviétique doit
être mise au courant des travaux avant
l'utilisation de la première bombe le
16i
1944 RC chch pour le persuader de
partager le
secretch refuse
catégoriquement alors à New York pour
rier Roosevelt à s V sans
succès
turch Roosevelt décide à Park en
septembre 1944 que toutes les recherches
atomiques mené aux États-Unis doivent
être gardé ultra
secrète près de 150000 techniciens
travaillent dans tout le pays soumis à
un contrôle accru à salamos les services
de sécurité sont particulièrement
[Musique]
vigilants en dépit de ce dispositif les
services soviétiques sont à pied d'œuvre
[Musique]
opener est l'objet d'un travail
d'approche mené par Vasil zarubin
résident du NKVD en poste à Washington
et sa femme éisabeth très liée à
Catherine openenheimer l'épouse du
savant au dire de sou Platov c'est
openheimer qui aurait fait venir cllaus
à Los
Alamos
[Musique]
fou communiste allemand est un physicien
qui a émigré en Grande-Bretagne en 1933
il est interné avec d'autres allemands
l'été 1940 dans un camp
canadien puis il est rappelé en 1941 à
l'Université de Birmingham par le
professeur Rudolph peyels pour un
travail en rapport la
guerre cher fou je ne peux pas pour
l'instant dévoiler le genre et le but de
ce travail mais il s'agit d'un travail
théorique qui comporte des problèmes
mathématiques d'une difficulté
notable ce travail m'a procuré beaucoup
de joie indépendamment de son extrême
importance si vous désirez parler de
cette affaire avant de vous décider vous
pouvez passer chez moi la semaine
prochaine à
Birmingham
en août 1942 fou obtient la nationalité
britannique il contacte alors le
responsable des communistes allemands en
Grande-Bretagne Jürgen
kzinski Klaus
f m ortlichen Leiter der Kommunisten von
dass er an einer ganz schrecklichen
Waffe arbeitet und ob ich glaubte dass
das für die sjetunion von Interesse sei
ich GAB IH dann die Verbindung zu der
entsprechen sjetischen Stelle
und das wares ich
in
hab son agent de biaison est Sonia la
propre sœur de kusinski c'est par son
canal que fou informe les Russes des
travaux britanniques sur la bombe
A Klaus fou arrive aux États-Unis le 3
décembre 1943 il prend l'engagement
d'observer une discrétion total sur les
recherches auxquelles il sera amené à
participer en janvier 1944 dans des
conditions mise au point par Moscou il
rencontre l'homme qui sera son agent de
liaison aux États-Unis
harryold
en aû 1944 fou rejoint l'équipe de à Los
Alamos où il occupe la chambre 17 dans
le dortoir
T12 chef du département théorique de
salamos l' côtoyé à cette
époque
salamos apprend que les États-Unis
travaill simultanément sur la
fabrication de de bomb l'une à l'uranium
l'autre plutonium et transmetes
information à harigold l de rendez-vous
à santaf les servic soviéti on acquis un
drstore qui le sert de PLA
tournante
fou ignore qu'un autre homme David
Greenglass technicien losalamos informe
les Russes par le billet de yolev en
poste à
[Musique]
Washington dès le lendemain de la mort
de Roosevelt le 12 avril Stimson
secrétaire à la Guerre révèle au nouveau
président Harry Truman le projet
manatan en juillet 1945 F est présent
parmi les savants qui se livrent au
dernier préparatif de la bombe atomique
il se rend à Alamogordo Robert
openheimer supervise les ultimes
opérations que savez-vous des relations
entre F
et je sais qu'il coopér avant tout et
une ha opinion
de
pH comme qui pouvit jouer un rôle
important un rôle positif dans la
solution du
problèmeomique est-ce que connaiss
l'état d'esprit et la sympathie que F
portait
àurss peut-être qu'il connaissait son
état d'esprit et C les RI dans unee
mesure mais
bien de dire qu'il savait que l'autre
était lié au renseignements
soviétiqu les renseignements soviétiques
ne le mentionnaient nulle part c'était
l'amitié avec leurss l'estime envers le
RSS une volonté sincère d'aider leurss à
ne pas être désarmé devant un ennemi si
dangereux une arme si dangereuse comme
la bombe
atomique le 16 juillet 1945 à l'aube les
conditions météorologiques sont
favorables peu après 5h du matin la
première bombe atomique de l'histoire
explose dans le désert du
[Musique]
Nouveau-Mexique
6 jours auparavant grâce aux
informations transmises par F derrière a
pu fournir à Staline un rapport qui
donne tous les détails sur la manière
dont la bombe a été
construite les documents c'est Oper et
ferm qui les ont transmis à fou et à are
coursier Fielding et c'est de là-bas
qu'on les a reçus ce n'était pas je le
répète des espions et agents mais des
savants qui ont sauvé le monde de la
guerre
n'oubliez pas une chose je voulais en
parler tous les savants qui étai en
contact avec nos employés à l'étranger
n'étai pas nos agents on instaur des
contacts amicaux au cours desquels on
obtenait des informations très
intéressantes on parlait de tous les
sujets
vous ont transmis des documents
intéressants bien
sûr vous vous souvenez-vous des noms
d'emprun que nous avons vu dans les
télégrammes hier
Charles star
c'est M encore une source c'est pon
corve je crois que
oui 1 juillet 1945 lorsque Stalin
Churchil et Truman se rencontrent pour
la conférence de Postdam le président
américain reçoit un message codé les
bébés sont nés normalement qui lui
apprend que les États-Unis sont
désormais en possession de l'arme
atomique lorsqu'il en informe Staline
quelques jours plus tard le dictateur
n'a pas l'air surpris et pour
cause
le 6 août 1945 le bombardier B29 décolle
pour le Japon et largue sur la ville
d'Hiroshima la première bombe
atomique
on dénombre 140000
Vic le 9 août une seconde B sur Nagasaki
fais 700
Vic TR annonce la capitulation du
Japon
les États-Unis faitent dans l'aliè la
fin de la Seconde Guerre
[Musique]
mondiale en septembre 1945 fou toujours
par l'intermédiaire d'arigol qu'
rencontre à santaf fait parvenir à
Moscou un nouveau rapport détaillé avec
le plan de la
bombe le 16 octobre 1945 le général
grovs au nom du secrétaire à la Guerre
remet à Robert openenheimer un diplôme
pour ses travaux le savant le remercie
en ses termes c'est avec estime et
gratitude que j'accepte de vos mains ce
parchemin au nom du laboratoire de
l'osalamos si les bombes atomiques ne
faisaient que s'ajouter aux arsenaux du
monde en guerre alors le temps viendrait
où le genre humain maudirait les noms de
losalamos et
d'Hiroshima Christopher and on vient de
voir dans le film à Los salamos qui a eu
une concentration de tous ses cerveaux
qui venait souvent d'ailleurs d'Europe
qui était antinazie convaincu alors quel
était l'état d'esprit de de ces savants
est-ce qu' il ne considérait pas que la
science é un domaine universel et que
finalement y compris sur ce domaine
atomique il y avait pas de secret
puisque l'URSS était un allié et
l'Allemagne était l'ennemi je crois
qu'il y avait à ce moment-là un certain
nombre de scientifiques britanniques
aussi bien qu'américains qui ont cru que
quand donné que l'Union soviétique
c'était une allié que cet allié avait
doir à savoir les recherches qu'on
effectuait en matière nucléaire à ce
moment-là parmi euur se trouvait un
ancien étudiant de Trinity hall tout
près de Trinity College c'est ici que
Alan nm a fait ses études de licences
pendant les années 30 et lui était pas
le
salamos non non lui il se trouvait il a
pénétré à
le l'équipe nucléaire dirigée par Johan
kcoft
physicien britannique très renommé à
Montréal
euh en
1940 42 mais il a il a joué un vol très
important surtout en
45 euh le 9 août 45 c'est-à-dire 3 jours
après
Hiroshima il a livré car son officier
traitant de du GRU c'est-à-dire le
service de renseignement militaire
soviétique non seulement des détails de
la bombe atomique largué sur le Japon 3
jours avant mais deux échantillons de
l'uranium son officier traitant Pavel
anglof lui a donné en récompense une
bouteille de whisky hélas non con mais
canadienne et 200ar canadien et alors je
voudrais qu'on s'arrête un instant sur
la personnalité de Robert openenheimer
puisque évidemment c'est il apparaît
comme le père de la bombe
américaine il était on sait qu'il av eu
des sentiments de gauche antinazie et
cetera et il y a toute une controverse
maintenant pour savoir quel a été son
rôle exact dans la livraison ou non
d'information à l'Union soviétique B
vous savez qu'il a évidemment ce ce
livre qui est paru qui a fait beaucoup
de bruit de les mémoires de Pavel Platov
qui disait que bien sûr openheimer
n'était pas un agent son stric mais
qu'enfin il avait été approché à
plusieurs reprises et qu'il a donné des
informations qu'il a fait passer des
rapports alors vous qui êtes historien
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
sur
openheimer a rédigé son souvenir a dité
plutôt son souvenir à l'âge de de 4 87
ans c'était trop tard il commet de
nombreuses erreurs ça c'est sûr et on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas être sûr sur ce
qu'il dit en qui concerne Oppenheimer
mais moi je crois que qu'il a commis
également beaucoup d'erreur en ce qui
concerne
Oppenheimer pour moi openenheimen
n'était jamais ESPI soviétique il a
dirigé avec beaucoup de succès le
laboratoire célèbre de los Alam après
Hiroshima il s'est interrogé très
fréquemment
sur les conséquences de de la
bombe atomique mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il a été jamais aspi en soviétique
les services soviétiques ont réussi
infiltrer à Alamos dans cet endroit très
bien garder un scientifique était un
agent de extrêmement haut niveau qui
était Claus fou je crois que c'était
assez extraordinaire dans les anales du
renseignement tout à fait extraordinaire
ce qui est maintenant certain c'est que
Klaus fous était l'ESPI atomique de
beaucoup le plus important de la 2e
guerre mondiale
Igor kartov qui a dirigé les recherchees
nucléaire en Russie mais c'est le père
c'est le pur soviétique on peut
dire effectivement oui il a déclaré
après la 2uxemme guerre mondiale que que
que les renseignements qu' qu'il a
tirait de de fou étaient je cite
textuellement euh d'une
importance exceptionnelle non Klaus fou
c'était vraiment le le père aussi bien
que kchartov de la bombe atomique
soviétique et ce qu'on sait actuellement
aussi c'est que la bombe atomique
soviétique c'était une copie exacte mais
très exact de la bombe nucléaire de la
bombe atomique américaine mais pourquoi
parce que les rapports qui é envoyé par
fou ont servi directement à à la
construction de cette B tout tout à fait
il avait je crois une drôle manière de
de contacter son officier traitant Harry
gold lui avait dit en 44 parce que c'est
en 44 qu'il avait commencé à travailler
à
losalomos qu'il devait chercher à à New
York quelqu'un dans la rue quelqu'un un
homme ganté qui portait avec des gant
oui mais qui n'était pas seulement ganté
mais qui portait des gants
supplémentaires à la main donc il a a
passé une journée chercher quelqu'un à
New
York qui qui portait quatre gant et il a
réussi et à partir de de ce moment-là il
a travaillé pour la KGB aux États-Unis
on lui avait demandé en même temps de
s'identifié auprès de de Harry gold en
tenant une balle de de tennis à la main
c'est comme ça que l'espion atomique le
plus important de dans l'histoire du
monde commenc à travailler pour le KGB
aux États-Unis maintenant on voit les
conséquences de ce travail de CL F avec
la construction en image de la bombe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soviétique le 13 août 1945 sur la Place
Rouge l'Union soviétique fête la
victoire sur la tribune la présence au
côté de Staline du général azenover
consacre l'Union des
alliés Beria l'homme de la police
politique est là bien
sûr la destruction d'Hiroshima a
accéléré les recherches soviétiques que
dirige toujours cour
chatov le 20 août 1945 un comité spécial
sur la bombe
CR la
direction ce comité
capé
[Musique]
méutor en novemb
1945 estcit par SAV Russ qui rencont
difficult pour prier
réacteurvos
[Musique]
savantoous d'ailleurs bien aidé
comment cela s'est-il
passé nous avions des difficultés
certaines et les spécialistes qui
travaillaient dans un domaine
particulier se sont trouvés dans une
impasse que
faire s'adresser à
opener
non on a décidé de s'adresser
à c'était en
46 à peu près vous savez je ne sais plus
très bien pour le
temps alors nous avons décidé de nous
adresser à bord qu'avons-nous fait on a
pris un jeune employé de mon département
s
terlety il était candidat en sciences
physiques et
mathématiques théoricien et on
l'envoyait chez
bord à l'époque le Danemark était libéré
des Allemands par l'Armée rouge
les r les siétiqu très
chaleureusement accil chez lui ce jeune
physicien qui
débutait il a appris de bord tout ce que
l'on voulait
savoirignit que
cétaitavit
enyé domain spécial mais très important
sortir de
l'impasse B nous a soufflé la
réponse mais déjà la grande alliance
entre alli laisse la place à la guerre
froide
[Musique]
dans le domaine atomique les pourparler
entre les Américains et les Russes pour
parvenir à une gestion pacifique et
commune de l'énergie nucléaire
[Musique]
échoue en décembre 19 36 le réacteur
russe entre en fonction sur ces images
inédites filmées par son assistant
kchatov fait
l'événement Beria porte la bonne
nouvelle à Staline le réacteur russe est
similaire à celui construit par Fermi 4
ans
[Musique]
auparavant grâce à cette mobilisation
frénétique des ressources humaines et
matérielles les Russes parviennent en 3
années à passer du réacteur à la
[Musique]
bombe les dernier préparatif en éta 49
sous l'œil de
Berard le 25 août la bombe russe
explose
la détection d'un nuage radioactif par
un avion américain prouve que l'URSS a
réussi à rattraper son retard en
Amérique c'est la
stupeur l'agence Stas confirme tandis
que vichinski ambassadeur aux Nations
Unies n'a pas de commentaire à
[Musique]
faire
en décembre c'est un beau cadeau
d'anniversaire pour les 70 ans de
Staline entourés pour l'occasion lechef
etourss et maintenant une puissance
nucléaire de quelle source disposai les
services soviétiques après
Hiroshima par d'autes sources disposa
d'un espion atomique qui était un ancien
étudiant de l'Université de Cambridge où
nous nous trouvons en ce moment Donald m
mclein qui a été le premier Cambridge a
beaucoup donné pour l'espionnage
malheureusement Cambridge a fourni des
espions non seulement au service
britannique mais au service soviétique
en même temps Donal mclein a été le
premier grand espience soviétique à être
recruté à à Cambridge et il a pénétré
sur les ordres du GB le Foreign Office
c'est-à-dire le ministère des Affaires
étrangères britanniques en en 35 en 44
il a été nommé Premier secrétaire de
l'ambassade britannique à Washington
poste où il a pour suivir suivre de près
la collaboration anglo-américaine en
matière nucléaire onempi qu'il
n'appréciait pas tellement il a dit de
l'espionnage atomique c'est comme d'être
préposé aux toilettes ça pu mais il faut
que quelqu'un que quelqu'un le fasse bon
mais lui il s'est dévoué quand même il
était très dévoué oui il était très
dévoué est-ce que fou aussi après son
retour à rwel après avoir quitté le
salamos a continué envoyer des des
informations certainement oui et est-ce
qu'on peut
apprécier combien de temps grâce aux
espions atomiques que ça soit mleen que
ce soit fou ce soit mais euh combien de
temps les les Russes ont gagnés euh dans
leur recherche une année minimum
peut-être même 2 années mais ils ont
quand même mis 4 ans entre la bombe
américaine et la bombe la bombe russe
c'est ça là mais c'est ça mais mais sans
l'espionnage il n'y aurait pas eu de de
bombe soviétique avant les années 50 on
va voir maintenant les arrestations euh
des aux États-Unis des espions
atomiques en mars 1946 Alan nounm savant
britannique qui travaillait sur le
projet de recherche nucléaire au Canada
est arrêté il renseignait les services
[Musique]
soviétiques ce sont les confidences
d'Igor gusenko qui ont permis
l'identification de
ma gusenko était un décrypteur en poste
à Otawa sa défection en septembre 1945
est un coup dur pour les
Russes il fournit aux Américains les
renseignements précieux sur le système
de chiffrage
soviétique aux États-Unis les
révélations sur l'espionnage soviéti
déclench un vent de psychose les mesures
de sécurité sont
renforcées les révélations de gusenko
permettent de casser le code utilisé par
les agents soviétiques en 1949 l'année
même où explose la première bombe russe
les Américains peuvent décoder les
messages que l'ambassade soviétique
adressé à Moscou pendant la
guerre dans un de ces messages les
agents du FBI trouvent des ind qui les
sur la piste des espions atomiques
agents
[Musique]
Robert
après de multiples recoups le FBI
identifie
[Musique]
cl depuis
1946 est rentré en Grande-Bretagne il
travaille à la fabrication de la
bombeomique britanque sous la direction
de rudol PE avec qui il poursuit ses
recherches s
[Musique]
Darwell le 27 janvier 1950 fou avoue à
l'inspecteur des service secret
britannique Willam SCON que depuis 1942
il livre au soviétique les secrets de la
bombe
atomique arrêté et signe ses
aveux
[Musique]
le 1er mars 1950 s'ouvre son
procès
F coupable devant le procureur sirley
choss il est condamné à la peine maximum
14 ans de
[Musique]
prison 59 fou est libéré pour bonne
conduite et part s'installer en
RDA les motivations de fou étaient
idéologique communiste fou ne voulait
pas que les Occidentaux soient les seuls
détenteurs de l'arme atomique plus tard
il dira le secret partagé en deux
signifiait la fin de la guerre ou du
moins la fin de la guerre de destruction
totale pour
l'humanité le scientifique n'est pas
neutre il doit avoir conscience de ce
qu'il invente et il doit agir comme il
l'entend pour ne pas être complice du
mal que contient son
[Musique]
invention
les aveux de fou sont permis de remonter
à harigold connu par fou sous le nom de
Raymon il était l'agent de liaison entre
le savant espion à Los Alamos et son
correspondant soviétique à New York
harigold livre le nom d'un trè homme
David Greenglass le technicien de Los
Alamos qui est arrêté le 15 juin
[Musique]
Greenglass est le beau-frère de Julius
Rosenberg qui dénonce à son tour Julius
puis Etel Rosenberg sont arrêtés en
juillet
[Musique]
1950 le dernier prévenu Morton Sobel ami
de classe de Julius Rosenberg est
également convaincu
[Musique]
d'espionnage ces arrestations
interviennent en plein mccartis
le sénateur Joseph McCarty brandit des
listes d'agents soviétiques qui sévisent
selon lui jusqu'au département d'État la
découverte du réseau soviétique confirme
les accusations spectaculaires de
McCarty cette atmosphère de chasse au
sorcières explique la sévérité du
procureur Koffman qui instruit à partir
de mars 1951 à New York le procès d'Etel
et de Julius
[Musique]
Rosenberg
alors que les Rosenberg procl leur
innocence David Greenglass livre les
pièces à
conviction des croquis d'abord qui
paraissent bien
anodin
et un objet de reconnaissance pour les
rendez-vous un couvercle de pot de
confiture dont chaque agent possédait un
[Musique]
morceau les Rosenberg sont incarcérés à
la prison de
singing le jury ne le accorde aucune
énante le procureur Kofman requier la
sentence de mort contre les
Rosenberg alors que l'assassin tu une
personne vous par contre en donnant à
l'Union soviétique les secrets de la
bombe atomique bien des années avant que
les savants russes ne soient CAPA de la
réaliser vous avez commis un crime bien
plus grave il est probable que des
millions d'innocents finiront un jour
par payer le prix de votre
trahison
harold est condamné à 30 ans de prison
greenlass à 15 en raison du concours
apporté à la justice Sobel C aussi de 30
ans l'annonce de la condamnation des
Rosenberg suscite une immense émotion
dans le monde les manifestations se
multiplient à Washington en Allemagne en
France et en Grande-Bretagne en faveur
de la grâce des
Rosenberg pour une grande partie de
l'opinion ils sont des martyr victime du
[Musique]
macartisme de nombreuses personnalités
le pape bidous lui-même intervienne
auprès du président
en
20 après le rejet de se recours les
Rosenberg sont conduit à la chaise
électrique de la prison de singing le 19
juin
[Musique]
1953 la dernière lettre de Julius
Rosenberg datée du 31 mai soulligne
jamais on ne pardonnera au gouvernement
américain ce scandaleux dénis de
justice jusqu'au bout les Rosenberg ont
clamé leur innocence ils auraient
probablement obtenu la grâce s'ils
avaient reconnu être des agents
soviétiques ils laissent deux jeunes
enfants les journaux annoncent en
première page exécution en France
Jean-Paul Sart écrit l'Amérique à la
rage
[Musique]
au cimetière les caméras sont encore là
pour surprendre la douleur de la
famille
6 semaines après l'exécution des
Rosenberg le 8 août 1953 la première
bombe russe à hydrogène explose les
sovitiqu Vinent de prendreavantage dans
la au
nucléair le père de la bombe russe
Ly
le 1 mars 1954 à bikini les États-Unis F
le tour exploser une bomb
thonléaire l'équ re les de Grand Est à
Nau rébl capacité de destruction est
bien plus éev que celui
1949 Edward Tayer le père de la bombche
justifie la politique nucléaire
américaine après la guerre je suis
revenu à
l'université j'ai Essé de retourner au
monde des idées et de quitter celui de
l'action mais les Russes ont fait
exploser leur bomb atomique alors j'ai
été certain qu'il existait un moyen de
fabriquer une bombe à hydrogène et que
les Russes le
trouveraient j'estimais qu'on devait
faire cette bombe et de plus je pensais
qu'on avait pas de raison de s'arrêter
et de ne pas découvrir ce qui pouvait
être
découvert décider de la façon de
l'utiliser et même si elle devait l'être
est un tout autre
problème mais on n pas le droit
d'arrêter le
progrès au printemps 1954 la commission
atomique américaine met en doute
l'intégrité politique de
robertonnu non coupable il est cependant
pr de s fonction de conseiller du
gouvernement et du droit d'accéder au
documents
[Musique]
secrets
tocess
Ofer
commiss
and PR was
so passant la course à la bombe
openheimer annonce déjà la future
coexistence
pacifique fou donne r gold har gold
greenlass greenlass les Rosenberg et on
arrive au Rosenberg évidemment c'est le
nom qui est le plus célèbre aujourd'hui
pendant 40 ans on a présenté les
Rosenberg comme des victimes du mcartis
aux États-Unis aujourd'hui évidemment on
sait que ils étaient vraiment oui des
agents soviétiquesou à la différence des
espirents atomiques britanniques à la N
class F les Rosenberg ont clamé leur
innocence jusqu'au bout mais aujourd'hui
il n a aucun doute sur leur culpabilité
parce qu'il y a des millions de gens à
travers le monde qui ont cru que qui
sans doute aujourd'hui encore sont
persuadés que les Rosenberg étit
innocents la culpabilité est admise
maintenant même en Russie c'est ça c'est
pas doute bon mais si on éétait pas dans
ce contexte du macartisme de la chasse
au sorcière est-ce qu' ils auraient été
condamnés à mort probablement pas à mort
d'ailleurs c'était des
idéalistes qu'on peut respecter qu'on
doit respecter toujours mais est-ce que
le le climat virulent d'anticommunisme
dans l'Amérique des années 50 n'a pas
totalement discrédité l'idée qu'il y
avait effectivement des des agents
soviétiques à gauche il y avait une
tendance n'est-ce pas à ce moment-là de
nier la réalité de l'p age soviétique de
nier par exemple la réalité de de
l'espionnage qu'effectuai les
Rosenberg aux États-Unis à droite il y
avait une tendance d'exagérer énormément
la réalité de cette espionnage
soviétique maintenant la guerre froide
est terminée nous pouvons n'est-ce pas
nous devons éviter ces deux
exagérations nous devons admettre
l'existence réelle d'un espionnage
important soviétique et nous devons
éviter en même temps les exagérations de
la guerre froide en ce qui concerne cet
espionnage et vous pensez qu'on
apprendra encore beaucoup de chose sur
la réalité de cet espionnage soviétique
oh sans doute surtout en France parce
qu'on connaî l'histoire de l'espionnage
soviétique en Grande-Bretagne on en
connaît la moitié en ce qui concerne les
États-Unis on n connaî presque rien en
ce qui concerne la France mais vous qui
êtes historien ici professeur à
Cambridge comment vous expliquer que on
parle si facilement en Angleterre des
espions et qu'en France on soit ce soit
un sujet tabou pour la France il y a
trois hypothèses possibles n'est-ce pas
on peut admettre l'hypothèse que l'Union
soviétique pendant les années 30 se
désintéressé totalement de la fr oui
c'est peu probable hypothèse absurde oui
deè hypothèse qu'il n'y avait pas de
recr possible en France hypothèse est
également absurde étant donné le nombre
de communistes de compagnons de route
beaucoup plus supérieur aux communistes
et aux compagnons de route en
Angleterre 3è hypothèse
euh il y avait pas mal de d'espions
soviétique recré en France au cours des
années 30 la se différence entre la
France et la grandbetagne c'est qu'en ce
qui concerne la France on en conna pas
toujours les noms voilà ça sera pour les
50 prochaines années je crois alors pour
terminer les livres qui nous ont aidé à
préparer cette émission deux excellentes
petites synthèses Claude Delmas la bombe
atomique édition complexe et l'air
atomique collection 20e c'est Casterman
de Roberto mayoki toutes les deux très
bien documenté tr TR pavés mission
spéciale de Pavel souop Platov mémoire
du maître espion paru au Seuil souo
Platov dont il était beaucoup question
dans cette émission et qui raconte
naturellement ses souvenirs du
département d'espionnage atomique mais
aussi bien d'autres choses de sa vie mes
camarades de Cambridge Yuri modine chez
Robert Laffond modine était l'agent
l'officier traitant des C de Cambridge
et il raconte comment pendant des années
il a travailler avec Burgess min Philby
Ken cross et blun et enfin un pavé le
KGB dans le monde chez faayard de
Christopher Andrew que vous avez vu tout
au long de cette émission qui a fait en
compagnie de og gordevski qui est un
ancien du KGB qui un transfuge c'est une
somme sur l'activité du KGB de 1917 à
1990 voilà c'est terminé dans un mois ce
sera à nouveau une histoire de
renseignement l'affaire de Rainbow
Warrior comment les services secrets
français ont coulé le Rainbow Warrior et
comment c'est devenu une affaire d'état
[Musique]
bonsoir